好，咱们接着说对白啊，说对白这个部分。
我们说这个场景对白对白其实没有，不应该也是场景并列啊。
行景里面包括环境。
动作和对白。
那对白为什么单拿出来呢？因为对白啊是大家。
也是很关心很很经常问的一个一个部分。
特别是还很多。
很多同学有担心啊。
就说老师我其实故事写的挺好的，我就是对白写不好。我因为嗯那个可能文那个文学啊文学功底差点意思。我跟你们说过，没有这回事情没有这回事情。
没有人许。
因为文学功力差而写不好对白。
对白跟文学功理没有关系。
你除非你写琼瑶句。
否则的话，跟你的文学功底没有关系。
我们这节课就来研究一下对白啊。
很多同学说，哎呀，我一定要写出好的对白，经典对白。
你说啥叫经典对白？我们先来聊聊这个问题啊，经年对白。
我是。
我是80年代初出生的，然后我是18岁到了上海。
我差不多是在那个年纪啊。
开始大面积的接触电影。
也就是那个。
2021世纪初啊。
开始大面积的看电影。
所以我跟那个年代的年轻人一样，我们对经典台词的认知是从周星驰启蒙的。
导致所有的年轻人都在模仿周星驰说话的方式，你知道吗？
曾经有一份真挚的爱情放在我面前，你知道每一次呃这个这个文艺表演或者小品表演都有人要把这个。
这这段台词再说一遍，你知道吗？
就是当时的网红。
相当于现在的就是这种网这这叫什么网络网络。
这叫什么我，反正就是很红的这种画吧。
就是都是从周星驰启蒙的。
多了周星驰的对吧？那个呃。
小人本住在苏州的城边，家中有屋又有田，对吧？还有那种谁敢逼我惨那个是吧？这种哎，那个那个周星驰各种。
各种金句。
啊，那就是从周星驰开门的对吧？
周星驰的好多台词。
还有那个当时那把刀离我有多少多少0.01公分之类的。
你说这是经典台词吗？
是，当然是经典台词，你记得这么深，他当然是经典台词。
还有一类经典台词，那就是琼瑶那一挂的那也真是当时也真是经典台词呀。
山无棱天地合，才敢与君绝。
诶，当时很很屌啊，很厉害啊。
是吧。
这种都属于经典台词。
但不是我们课上去。
不是我们这节课我想给你们讲的。
台词因为这种台词啊。
他不是你可以模仿的。
你当时有很多人开始模仿这种写法，你知道吗？就周星驰以后就在自己的片子里面故意写上呃这个那个那个呃当时谁他离我只有多少多少公分，对吧？我这一拳呃这个重达34.957000克，就故意写这种很长很啰嗦的台词，以为。
在模自己在模仿周星驰，以为这是好台词的写法，其实是错误的，这个思维是错的。
它的原理是什么呢？是人家火了。
是是人家那个戏火了，人火了。
然后他的。
大家才去追捧他说过的话。
所以他是这个这个逻辑反了，而不是说他这个台词写的漂亮，让他火了。
相当于大师。
在闹笑，你光看到闹笑的那那一块的，对吧？你看到了一个经典作品这这然后你就觉得哪哪都是对的。
这个这个这个思路不对啊，因为那那个相当于他就是故意不好好说话，然后你可学去了。
这个思路我给大家举个更典型的例子吧啊，什么叫这个片子火？但是这个台词其实并不好。
我这个之前课里面，我曾经在别的课上跟同学们说过这个事儿，我说。
夏洛特烦恼。
好看吧，下洛的防盗很很好看，也很火。
毋庸置疑很火呀，沈腾玛丽就是这部戏。
开始火起来的呀。
我说这个夏洛特烦恼里面你能记得住的台词，一定有那句。
呃，大爷呃，马冬梅住这吧？马什梅。
马冬梅马冬什吗？
马冬梅什么冬梅马东，哎，算了吧，大爷。
对吧一定有这场戏吧。
一定有这场戏吧，这几句台词。
也被也也被普遍认为是经典台词吧。
经常被拿出来再再再剪一下，或者是再。
看一下什么的。
小视频里面经常会看到这个。
恕我直言啊。
这场戏是废戏。
真的是费析。
因为这场戏没有作用。
这场戏情想表达什么？
你想表达马冬梅住的环境很险恶。
邻居。
都都不是好人。
跟主线没有关系，这场戏是沈腾去找他。沈腾呃，这个这个功成名就之后。
心里。
遭遇挫折，心里难受的时候，想去找找冬梅，想去找找他的。
原配吧对吧？因为他是个穿越系嘛，原配夫人找一找马冬梅。
马冬梅住的那个环境，邻居很坏，跟这个信息无效，没有用，不需要表达。
你想表达还有什么信息？呃，沈腾找玛丽千辛万国，沈腾找马冬梅千辛万国。
没有用。
也没有表达这个信息。所以说这场戏其实是场废弃。
从剧本的角度啊，咱不能说人家啊人家红了就所有地方都是对的。
他红，他当然这个戏好，但是这场戏是场废戏。我为什么拿这场戏举例子呢？我们单位的我不怕得罪他们，好吧，这场戏真的是场废戏，他就是为了搞笑。
就是为了搞笑，博大家一笑。
对于故事来说。
是没有用的。
是废了。
但是在一场废戏中，你认为那个台词都很棒。
为啥就是因为熄火的。
熄火了，你反过来觉得哪哪都可爱，都挺好的，明白吗？
这就是我说的这个这个。
我们对经典台词的理解啊。
不能。
说啊那那些台词火遍大家南北的那些台词就是我们学习的对象，你反了。
反了。
对吧。
这这这就有点像什么呢？就你你你觉得啊马云是中国首富，然后你就照着马云的头型理了个发。
反了，他不是因为有那个发型，他才发了财，他是发了财之后，你觉得他那个发型真可爱呀，所以反了，你知道吗？所以你不能学学那些呃大师呃什么都学优秀作品里面就是觉得全是经典，全是对的。
首先这个这个这个这个思维先要改变一下，我跟大家说的是这个意思，好吧，还有就琼瑶的那些琼瑶也有自己的特色，而且误误误让让观众误以为呃，大家应该那么写。因为我经常看到有一些年轻人在写写剧的时候，还在走那个风格。
就比如说。
我其实也写过啊，就早期写偶像剧的时候，也会觉得你写的越越文艺。
就乐队对吧？
遇见你。
呃，用尽了我。
前半生的运气离开你，耗尽了我后半生的眼泪。
是吧就就然会整出这种句式。
这种。
嗯，也也也不可取也不可取，很幼稚。
也是搞反了。
对吧言情剧不要去去去模仿，就你现在如果在写偶像剧，就不要写这种。
不要写这种这种话。
还有装逼的词儿。
我当时也以我年轻的时候，我现在给你举的都是我年轻的时候走过弯路啊。
我年轻的时候，我还觉得装逼的词儿也是一种。
文艺也是一种牛逼，也是呢会成为经典台词。
啥叫装逼的台词？我当时都总结出方法了。
我当时写装逼台词，我都总结出自己的小方法了，啥方法呢？就是我想写装逼台词的时候，我就让我的角色答非所问。
啥叫大非所问啊？比如说我写过，哎，就哎咱就说上一上上一场戏，咱举过那个例子那个那个。
小弟跑进来跟黑老大汇报一件事情，对吧？汇报说，哎，老大，你那个拜把兄弟，咱二当家真的背叛你了。
是吧他干了什么坏事儿，什么坏事，什么坏事儿，您看。
要不要？
宰了他。
你黑老大在吃炸酱面吗？
装逼开始。
从我们一开始。
我说了吗？答非所问即可呀。老大要不要宰了他很明确的一个问句，要不要宰了他啊，老大吃面。
我小时候在农村长大。
家里特别穷。
我们家住的在村最里边那一户。
我每天去上学。
要经过村西头。
那条小路。
村西头那家人家。
养了只大狗。
非常凶恶。
而且没有酸。
我每天从那里走。
都非常害怕。
他每次都会冲出来咬我。
我都拼尽全力逃逃跑。
有时候我晚上做噩梦都是那个狗。
扑过来咬我的情景。
导致我也不敢去上学，开始验学，都不想去上学。
这件事情。
我跟我爸爸说了，我爸爸去找。
找那家人交涉。
后来我再从那走的时候，我发现。
他们把那只狗拴上了。
有绳子了。
啊后继续又吃几口面条，然后小弟在还听得云里雾里。大哥我问你要不要宰了他哎啊，现在云里雾里。
。
所以我就可以安全的去上学了。
那天我就开开心心的从家里出发。
走到村西头。
路过那家人家。
我喂了那只狗。
包着老鼠要的馒头。
把他毒死了。
因为我不相信那根绳子。
我只相信我自己。
小丽。
老大，我懂了走了。
就写这种台词啊。
年轻时候特别热衷写这种台词，觉得还像跟教父似的啊。
其实就是不好好说话，这不叫经典台词。
不好好说话，明白吗？
你熄火了，再反过去看说哎呀，这段台词真牛，其实它不对，这个思路不对。
不应该这么写。
真正好的台词啊。
好的台词是什么台词？
好的台词分两种。
一种。
是京剧。
我们可以统统称为金句。
京剧类的。
我们是京剧类的台词。
他是怎么写出来？
一定是贴着人设。
或者说要贴着人物写。
贴着人设贴着人物写出来那种。
京剧。
很抽象啊，我给大家举举例子。
比如说。
虎门的世界。
楚门的事件，金凯丽的楚门的世件里面的。
纪念台词是什么？
出门。
那个男主角叫。
出门嘛出门。
楚门每次碰到别人打招呼，都是说。
呃，早上好。
对吧然后接着说一句，哎呀，以防我今天再也碰不见你了，我就在问你下午好，晚上好，晚安。
然后他再走。
这就是跟着他人设走的呀，他是一个极其nice极其有礼貌的人。
所以说这句台词他就表达了这个他的人设，就我碰到你，我不光跟你说早上好，我担心今天再也碰不到你了。
我没有机会像跟你问问，下午好，晚上好和晚安。
所以我虽然现在是早上，但是我一并都问候了。
表达了楚门是一个非常有礼貌，非常nice甚至非常天真的人。
所以这成为了。
朴门的金剧。
浙江牛逼台词。
这叫牛逼对白。
这叫词儿这叫好词儿。
贴着人设走。
明白这意思吗？
还有像这种牛逼的人设呃，牛逼的贴着人走的台词，那个当幸福来敲门。
当幸福来敲门是威尔史密斯主演的威尔史密斯跟他儿子。
一对黑人父子。
破产的黑日父子。
努力打拼在华尔街。
从睡厕所、睡地铁、睡睡露宿街头身无分文到在华尔街打拼起来。
有一场戏。
他。
跟他儿子在路边，他儿子在打篮球。
他儿子说，我要成为职业篮球运动员。
然后他跟他儿子，他就说他说哎。
他你的梦想要现实一点，他说嗯呃咱们家没有什么运动基因天赋。
你要当职业运动员这条路，我觉得。
不太现实。
他说完这句话之后。
他儿子就就就就就。
就很伤心。然后他发现那人很伤心之后，他觉得自己说的这句话不对。
然后他又重新说。
他说。
你要记住。
永远不需你不要让别人告诉你，你不能做什么。
这个就是贴他的人设了。因为他自己作为一个黑人，作为一个没有什么文文凭文化的黑人。
他想在土二街做股票经纪人，做做。
做一个上流社会的人，他也在做一件别人告诉他你不可能做到的事情。
所以他在这时候，他儿子想要当NBA球员。
他意识到。
我不。
我凭什么打击我儿子的梦想？我自己不也跟我儿子一样，抱着一个篮球。
妄想自己。
能进nBA吗？
所以他当时应该那句台词，我记得是don't ever let somebody tell you，you cannot do something.
就别让别人告诉你不能做什么事。
这就是。
贴着人设走了。
他虽然是说给他儿子听的，但是说的是他自己的人设，明白这意思吗？
根据这人设走的。
还要根据人设走的。
还有什么？
能力越大，责任越大。
这个人人都听过经典台词，蜘蛛侠。
对吧蜘蛛侠这个这个。
这就经典台词嘛，那能力越大，你的责任越大，这太符合了，能力越大，责任越大。
你觉得扛事儿啊，你不能说你得到这个这个啪啪这个这个蜘蛛侠，这个他是偶得的嘛？这个能力是偶得的呀，它不是天生的呀，被蜘蛛咬了嘛？你偶得了这个能力之后，你就觉得。
啊，你就你就牛逼了吗？你就能力大了嘛？能力越大，责任越大。
这这这这才叫牛逼台词呀。
对吧只是贴着人设，贴着人物。
贴着人物走的台词其实是最容易让观众记住认可的那黄晓明说的那个我不要你觉得我要我觉得。
这就是贴着人物的台词呀。虽然当时在综艺节目里面马上成为京剧了呀，我不要你觉得我要我觉得。
一下把这个人物就活灵活现呀。
对不对？然后那个流行花园里面那个。
呃，那个老板呢道道歉有用的话，要警察干嘛？
对吧那个就道明寺。
这台词就表现他的人设和性格呀，这种就是观众容易记住，这叫好台词，这叫好台词。我们说好台词那个。
那个那个。
呃，泰坦尼克号里面是最多的。
泰坦尼克号那个。
呃，地下布料。
的进入上流社会吃饭的那场那场台词呃，那那段台词。
那也是传世经典呀，他进到上他在底层船舱，他是个穷人吗？他进到混进上流社会，跟女主角的一家人全是有钱的上流社会，一家人吃饭，各种复杂的规矩，开餐就是鱼子酱啊。
那场戏，然后一家人那肯定故意刁难他嘛？你是个穷小子呀，那肯定刁难他呀。哎呦，你住哪儿啊？哎呀，那个三等舱里面什么情况呀？就。
句句刁难他，他从容应对，因为他他很他的内心很。
很美丽的，所以他就会觉得嗯。
他会觉得很好，然后他的那那几句台词。
也是传世经典符科拉的人设，对吧？然后他说。
我觉得这样挺好的。
对吧我有健康的身体，我有这个这个呃良好的心态。然后这个呃我每天醒来都面对不一样的挑战。但是具体台词我不记不记得那么清楚啊，但最后的经典台词就是你永远不知道明天会发生什么，所以。
make each day count。
过好每一天。
首先这是他的人设。
对吧这是他的最强项，就是他一无所有，但是他珍惜。
当下珍惜每一天。
to make each day count嘛。
这是他的人设。
然后我们说同时她又是女主角人设的短板。
哎，你看看啊，我们说爱情系眠男女主角是互补吗？
那等于是他输了男主角的最强项，就是女主角的最弱项嘛。
男主角说我每天都过得精彩。
to make each day count。
这是男主的。
人设的强项，同时又是女主人设的短板。
那等于这一句。
就双关了呀。
关两个事儿了，很厉害，而且我还跟你说，他还三管，还关他啥事儿。
就说你永远不知道明天发生什么，所以你过好每一天。
对不对？泰坦尼克号啊。
多点题呀。
你永远不知道明天发生什么，过好每一天什么贫穷，什么富贵，什么上流什么下流。
对不对？我很精彩，我给你呼吸的一样的空气，看到一样的海浪。
所以这个这句台词。
tomake each day count.
过好每一天。
就是经典代词就很厉害，他贴着男主的人设，弥补女主的人设暗示。
还暗示这个这个整体故事的走走向。
厉害吧，这台词就很厉害。
我们说这是一类好台词，京剧类贴着人设，贴着人物走的。
还有一类好台词啊。
是跟着情境来的。
跟着情境来的，我们说有的台词也是传世经典。
但是首先啊他不是瞎写的，他不是我说的那种情况，就是呃大师瞎写的，不是，但呢他也不是金剧，也不是对白。那那种台词为什么能那么厉害呢？
我们还说那个泰坦尼克号刚才举的泰坦尼克号例子。
呃那男女主角。
在那个那个甲板上第一次相遇的时候，女主要要跳海啊，男主说你跳我也跳，youju,I jump.
经典吗？传世经典。
牛逼不牛逼太牛逼了。
但这个是词牛逼吗？
你跳我也跳。
假设抛开情境。
你去跟别人说，哦，我今天想到一句非常棒的台词，然后就哎说来听听，叫你跳我也跳。
人家会觉得你这个牛逼吗？不会觉得。而且你说这样的台词需要你的文学功底吗？需要你华丽的词藻吗？你跳我也跳。
又juIju。
对吧。
它是来自于情境。
就是你这种台词实际上是你把情境写好了。
反而这时候啊。
据说这种台词它牛逼就牛逼在哪儿，牛逼在简练。
牛逼在简历。
你情境牛逼的时候，你反而越简练越好。
我再举回我刚才那个例子，我说那个小弟说老大要不要杀了他？
你说了他妈一堆废话，说了他妈5分钟。
对吧。
你如果情境营造的好。
我看过一个很老的黑帮片。
50年代左右的吧，也不叫黑帮片吧，一个就是一个坏人。
那个那个那个老师叫什么来着？
时间还是叫什么？忘了啊，我忘了一个就是一个非常老的演员，他演了一个坏人。
就非常的那个情景就非常好。那个小弟在那说。
哎呀，那个谁谁谁怎么怎么如何如何如何不好。然后那个那个黑老大他嘻笑嘻嘻的杀了他吧。
就说了四个字，啥他。
一点不把杀人当回事，反而这场戏有力量。
明白吗？你如果情境做的好，你反而要少说，不要去讲你小时候那个在农村长大，村头有一条狗，显得你倍儿深沉，还给人讲一个寓言故事。
那反而是不对的，就情境好的好时候，你有一个好的情境，你的弹台词反而越简练，越能成为经典。
又降挨降。
一跳我一跳。
还有更呃还有一个更极端的例子，华华语电影的华语电影的顶峰之作之一。
无间道。
无间道牛逼不牛逼？
那拍的相当好呀，各国都翻拍，好莱坞也翻拍，好莱坞翻拍就迪卡普奥演的呢。
对吧好莱坞的版Dup演的呀。
我们说经典台词你能记得住的。
对不起。
我是警察。
谁知道？
啊，天台上那场戏不是经典吗？
那个那个那个那个梁朝伟从后面呃，那个那个拿枪逮着刘德华了吗？
对吧刘德华让让他说可不可以给我个机会，对吧？我想做个好人。
然后那个梁朝伟，对不起，我是警察。
刘德华说。
谁知道？
这个。
经典台词。
用到你什么。
文学功底了。
小学毕业就能写出来。
对不起，我是警察，谁知道？
对吧。
台词本身。
就那么回事。
就是情境，你先把情境营造好了。
然后你台词。
简练有力就能成为经典。我不是说这个台词是随随便便写出来的啊，不是这个意思啊，我是说你情境牛逼了之后，你的台词越简练，越精准越好。
明白吗？
所以。
好的台词要么来自于人设，要么来自于牛逼的情境。
牛逼的冲突。
但是都不都是不啰嗦的台词。
都不是那种呃你不可理喻，你无理取闹，你什么什么我哪有不可理喻，哪有无理取闹。
那那种不是那种。
不是那种。
真正牛逼的台词。
要么贴着人设来。
要么跟着婷婷走。
好吧，那我们就来举这是举例子啊，这是给你们讲一下什么叫好的台词。
那我们就来。
那我们就来这个这个说一下。
台词这个这个对白啊这个词儿啊。
到底应该怎么写，就你怎么写。
对吧我们说的实惠的，你怎么写？首先写台词有一个最基本的原则。
有一个最基本的原则。
就是。
单写。
这是一个最基本的原则。
你不要比如说有三个角色，甲乙丙。
你不要甲写什么，甲说什么，乙说什么丙说什么。
你把甲说的全部写完，再说再写乙的，再写丙的这是一个最基本的套路，你就要分开写，为什么分开写，为什么让人分开写？
你要带入每一个角色呀，你要带入每一个角色。
甲是一个什么样的性格，什么样的背景，什么样脾气？
遭遇什么样的事儿，以及他在这个事件中什么立场，你先完全见到假。
把假的台词写完。
然后再进完全进到乙。
去同哪些意义。
是这么写的，不是甲乙丙、甲乙丙、甲乙丙，他三个人在这对话，你就三个人哐哐写，那你最后肯定写不明白。
这是最基本的写法，这个一定要注意。好吧，带入每一个人，而且要表演着写甲是一个什么什么样的性格，他在这件事情有什么样立场，你带你进甲里面演着写。
明白吗？带着表演写。
你自己演演技不好，没关系，又没人看。
我们说编剧是书房里的影帝呀。
关起门来，谁能看见你自己演。
你去表演这个奖。
去写。
这是一个最基本的原则，就是要单写，不要甲乙丙那么写，是甲写完再写乙，再写丙。
好吧，然后第二。
我之前也说过。
你那个素材库。
我不是说过吗？让你记吗？
你要写好台词，你的素材库必须丰富。
你必须知道每一种人说话的。
呃方式说话的。
而套路。
你那个小本要大量的记素材，在这个地方是要发挥作用的，要调动用自己的素材库。
比如说那个那个我最近还还还还还那个还记那个呢。
就别人说说什么山东人说话还爱倒装。
啥叫倒装？就说这个事儿不靠谱吧，我觉得。
他们就说这是山东人的说话的特点。
然后我就在在记这个玩意儿。
你那你你你如果写到一个山东人说话的时候，你就可以写道庄嘛？我认为。
是吧你这个写倒装吗？就你这种素材啊。
多记。
多分类。
你你写的时候，你调用起来，你的人物就说台词就会。
更有趣更有辨识度，也更贴合他的角色，他的处境。然后这是第二个。
呃，方法就是大量的调用你的素材库，不要自己闭门造车，好吧，3。
3、小心。
问答陷阱。
小心问答建解。
就写台词啊，特别是初学者，包括我刚开始写的时候。
你如果写了两个人对话的一场戏。
大量的对白。
你就会发现。
全是问答形式。
全是问答形式。甲问一个问题，乙回答甲又问一个问题，乙又回答乙问问题，甲又回答。
你就会发现你的台词有大量的问答模式。
其实你生活中。
你每天跟人说话，哪有那么多问答模式。
为什么会出现这种情况？
我们说这是一个陷阱啊，你小心你台词，你对白中的问答模式，为什么会出现这种情况？
原因在这儿。
就你们一场戏想要扛的信息很多。
但是你表达扛这些信息的手段有限。
你就死命的用对白去扛。
动作跟环境扛的太少。
死命的用对白去扛。
你想表达的信息多。
不是问题。
只要这些信息是有效的，你想多表达没有问题，这儿我不拦着你，你有本事表达完，我不拦着你，只要这信息有效。
但是一定要小心问答陷阱。
哎。
隔壁那个老张为什么成天凶巴巴的？
这你就有所不知了，他小时候命可苦了。
怎么个苦法呢？他从小父母双亡，自己一个人整，就你想表达老张的身世，你在你的大纲里面，在你的梗盖里面，你写过老张的身世。
然后呢，你觉得这个实验师对你的剧情很有用。
你最后把它落在哪了？
你他妈就落在另外两个角色，他闲扯淡上了。
明白这个意思吧？
两个人闲闲扯淡。
大量的信息大量的信息用问答模式表达。
知道吧？
大量的信息问答模式表达。
所以你去看那种。
呃，你的剧本或者说初学者的剧本里面有大量的，这你就不知道了。
恕我直言啊，恕你妹恕你直言，你别直言了。
我开始写的时候大量的啊就一呃一场戏里面有五个恕我直言，6个，这你就不知道了。
所以一定要小心这个事情，问答模式。
一定要避免我我让你避免给你不是说不让你表达信息啊，一定要理解这个事儿啊，把它放在动作呃，把它环放在环境和动作里面可以表达的。
老张呃那个那个绅世很苦，呃，很穷，不一定非要另外俩老娘们在这叨逼叨叨逼叨。
把它说出来对吧？你可以环境的也可以表达老张。
这个这个呃那个是哭出声吧。
动作也可以表达老张是苦出身吧，他的习惯动作他的。
他的他的他做事的那种风风格，做事的方式，对吧？一看就是农民。
一看就是农民出身半辈子的农民，你通过环境描述动作描述。
其他的描述。
解决不了吗？
完全可以解决呀，为什么非要两人叨逼叨叨逼叨说人老张。
呃那个生活条件不好呢，离婚带个孩子从农村出来，你俩快别说了，对吧？就就是千万要要要。
要避免这个问答模式，这个是。
初学者或者是呃这个也不算初学者，年轻编剧在从业的前几年里很容易遇到的问题。老老编剧也也有时候也会。
一不小心就就就这这都是经验之谈啊，我告诉大家一定要注意。
然后这是第三点。
第四。
写每句台词之前。
先写潜台词。
明白什么叫潜台词吧，这很很很简单的对吧？就像我说的那个那个呃呃泰坦尼克号那个呃丁卡布料跟上流社会那些人吃饭，对吧？那些人假装关心他的生活方式，假装关心他的那个哎，那你家在哪儿啊？潜台词就是你个穷逼没房子吧。
是吧。
就是。
每一句话是有潜台词的那这种台词往往在戏里面就是比较精彩的。有潜台词的。
这种词儿是比较精彩的。
所以你。
在写对白的时候啊，你可以尝试先写潜台词。
先写潜台词。
然后再写正定台词。
对吧你碰到一个呃老朋友。
你的呃碰到一个老同学，十年没见了。
他想跟你炫富呀。
对吧。
那他的潜台词就是我比你有钱，我比你有钱我比你有钱。
你先把这个表达出来，然后再写正经台词，他见了你们面你的面，第一句话呃，见了你面，你们俩坐下。第一句话就是哎福员，我门口那宝马停那没事吧。
对吧？
你写这种台词的时候，你为什么能写出这种台词呢？你为什么知道在这里要写这种台词呢？你需要先写潜台词，就是这两个人见面。
潜台词有哪些？
你先写出来，然后再把它变化成真正的台词，这也是一个创作习惯。
大家。
也可以学一下。
也可以注意一下。
好吧，然后第5个。
还有一个很好用的方法。
很好用的方法就是你如何把你的人物的台词写到。
入木三分，写到非常贴合他，然后又写到这个你的戏里面常常有多个人物呀，每个人物的台词都能够。
呃，非常贴合他。
切合有有有有有区别，有自己的特色，对吧？
怎么还有一个办法，怎么做呢？
就是给每个角色写日记。
这是一个很好用的方法。
这个办法很好用。
特别适合你写电影的时候。
呃，写电视剧也可以啊。
就是说几个主要人物。
你给他们写日记。
给他们写日记。
还要写日记啊。
来，你戏里面今天会发生一件事儿吧。
你的几个主主要角色是不是都参加了？
对吧。
那么他们共同都经历这个事儿了呀。
你可以完全可以通过他们每一个人的角度写一篇日记嘛。
今天。
迪卡布料奥去上流社会那个那个那个餐厅吃了一顿饭。迪卡布廖奥回到家写了一篇日记，今天他妈上楼。
对吧借的那双鞋给我脚挤得够呛。
没有正经西装呀。
对吧什么都是偷来的呀，借的那双鞋给我脚挤够呛，上楼的时候还给我绊了一脚。
他最头大的就是他妈上叉子那一瞬间，一排叉子，我也不知道该用哪个，就从他的角度先写遍日记。
然后那那个女主角的那个未婚夫也写篇日记啊，今天好好的在那吃饭。
不知道哪来一个穷小子，还自称画家，对吧？看就是不顺眼，关键是我未婚，我未婚妻对他还不错，对吧？口口声声，俩人说是朋友，这小逼啊，就每个人的角度写一篇日记，你就会更加进入每一个角色。
你在创作一个。
正经戏的时候，创作一个你重视的戏的时候，创作一个你想要好好表达好好呈现的剧本的时候。
我建议你。
可以尝试给戏中的几个重要角色。
每个人写一篇日记。
当然，这个不出现在正文里。
当然他不出现在你的剧本里。
但是几个重要的角色。
他在短短的，反正也没几天嘛，在这几天的事里面。
他们每个人给他写写日记。
这就是我说的。
关于对白，我想给大家讲。
对白好的对白。
我认为有两种来源，一种来自于人物。
我们说是京剧型。
特别贴人物，特别贴人设。
这个。
还有一种就是情境情境牛逼，你这个情境牛逼了。
你的台词。
反而要越简练，越简洁越好。
越简单越有力量。
你跳我也跳。
对不起。
我是警察，谁知道就仨字，谁知道。
有力量呀。
就是情境牛，然后如何写出这样的好的台词呢？
我个人认为可以从。
这五个方向。
是你需要注意的五个方向。第一个是普世的啊，第一个是所有的编剧老师都会这么跟你说。
你要分开写每个人的台词。
不要不要什么一块儿记流水账写。
第二个就是我说过的，你要调用你的素材库，你一定要调用你的素材库。
你素材库里面会有形形色色人来说过的话。
这个不是你简简单单。
就能一下模拟出来的。
有素材是很重要的。
什么样人爱说什么样的话，对吧？比如说我我我就记得。
那个。
呃，我。
提名者。
就有这种我我曾经分类有一类人叫提名者，就动不动人就说名字。
动不认动不动就说别人的名字。
以显示自己的牛逼，他往往提的是一些厉害人物的名字。
对吧。
这个这个。
比如说他如果认识名人。
对吧。
那个那个比如说他认识黄晓明，他就说哎呀，昨天跟小明一起这样，那个上回小明跟我说啊，就他俩要提这个名字。
当然不一定是明星啊，可以是你们地方的名人。比如说你们县里的首富。
假设叫叫军强是吧？王军强王总是你们县里的首富。但在他嘴里呢，他就是说哎呦上个月军强那边啊什么。
你看你这种就是一种。
一种人的行文方式，他说话的方式嘛，你就可以记下来嘛。
分类叫提名者爱提名字。
爱提名字。
就是你的素材库就就就就发挥作用。
发挥作用。
然后第三就是千万要避免问答和陷阱。
千面千万要避免这个。
为什么会出现问答陷阱？就是因为你你的信息。
你想表达的信息，你没地儿搁。
没地儿哥，你就在那瞎鸡巴扯是吧？你根本就不知道这些年我我经历了什么，你经历了什么呀，就开始给人讲起来。
你这些经历什么跟这个剧情有什么关系啊？有一点点关系，但是你不要讲呀。
你不要用嘴讲是，对不对？
不要去这呃Q and的A模式，我们说叫是吧？不要有这个啊。4就是尝试先写潜台词，这样的话可以让你的台词更立体，更有趣。
先写潜台词。第五。
就是又是一个呃独门技巧，给你的主要角色写写日记。
学写日记。
好吧。
这就是关于台词，我想给大家说的台词主要是想给大家表达一个什么呢？台词真的不需要文学功底，不要去给我写琼瑶台词，那种文学功底没有必要的对吧？
呃，我们写的台词就是。
很平时，但是很有力量，你跳我也跳，这小学生都能写出来。
对不对？
不要担心这个问题，写写好台词呃，我们是有方法的。
我我我这里举例子，我说那个那个。
那个那个那个泰坦尼克号。
卡布廖奥上上楼去和富人阶层吃了一顿饭。那场戏我们大家也一块看一下，好吧。
, Mr. Dawson.
Best I've seen, ma'am, hardly any rats.
Iturns out that Mr. Dawson is quite a fine artist. He was kind enough to show me some of his work to.
Roose and I differ somewhat in our definition of F, not to impute in your work, sir.
you your is wonder Mr. Andrews truly you.
Do take no caviar for me, thanks, never did like it much.
And where exactly do you live Mr. Dawson Well right now my is theMS Ti After that I'm God's good humor and how it you means I work my way from place to place you know, tramp steamers and such but I won my ticket on Titanic here a lucky handed poker a very lucky hand.
All life is a game of luck A real man makes his own luck, got right.
And you find that sort of rootless existence appealing, do you?
Yes, ma'am, I do.
I mean, got everything I need right here with me, got hair in my lungs and a few blank sheets of paper, I mean I love waking up in the morning not knowing what's going to happen or who I'm going to meet where I'm going to wind up.
Eer not I was sleeping under a bridge and now here I am on the grand a ship in the world having champagne with you fine people I take some I figured life's a gift and I don't intend on wasting it.
You never know what hand you're going to get dealt next, You'll learn to take life as it comes at you you go count.
make each day count.
Well said Jack here呀 here呀.
没给看。
没一个。
对，就是这场戏啊。
我们看啊这个每个人的台词都很有特点，有潜台词。
对吧然后有有有符合人设符合人物的金剧。
也有这种情境下。
很简练很有力量的台词。
这场戏就是标准的。
好台词的典范。
我们今天看了两场戏。
一场是。
风骚律师。
第一季第1集的。
那场碰瓷戏，还有一场是泰坦尼克号。
这个这个男女主角。
一起吃饭的一场戏。
我们这一节课不是讲场景怎么写吗？我们说场景里面有环境，有动作，有对白，很多同学卡在这儿了。
不知道怎么样描述这些东西，把环境描述明白，把动作写明白和台词写明白。
我们做一个练习。
这两场戏已经拍出来了。
摆在这儿。
你把它翻回去。
写成剧本。
就是照着这场拍出来的戏，1比1的还原成剧本。
反向操作。
不是剧本开成戏，是把戏写成剧本。
然后再去读你的剧本，看看你描述的东西。
对不对？你有没有把场景，把环境、动作和对白都描写清楚？
做一个这个练习，好吧，这是这节课的作业，把这两场戏翻回翻回剧本。
下课。